olá meu nome é ricardo e hoje eu irei a
apresentar sobre furacão foi retornado e
nós temos que tomar cuidados que nos
lugares onde tem também pode furacão e
fãs o mesmo fenômeno porém localizados
em diferentes lugares quando ocorre
nessa região entre o oceano pacífico que
o leste e oceano atlântico é chamado de
furacão e quando ocorrem nessa região é
que ela não pode você não pacificou
oeste é chamado o editor fã
já os tornados são redemoinhos
atmosféricos são muito mais forte e
destrutivos pior tornado da história foi
na cidade de morte em outro a roma nos
estados unidos da américa que ocorreu em
21 de maio de 2003 mais de 170 mil
pessoas estava no caminho do tony o pior
furacão da história foi o furacão
patrícia que passou por miami e devastou
o iene e foi em 23 de outubro de 2015
eu fiz uma pesquisa para ver se a água
era capaz de parar o fenômeno e
descobrir se um pesquisador chamado
defensor que fez um dispositivo é capaz
de parar esse fenômeno
o dispositivo funciona assim quando a
quando a água quente que a superfície
encontra esse aro e chega aqui gera uma
certa pressão para fazer com que desça e
misturei água quente com a filha
o dispositivo funciona é barato mas
ninguém ouve interesse em luanda regente
positivo apesar do tornado a ser mais
descritivo o furacão mais perigoso pois
dura mais tempo ea maior velocidade do
furacão é de 249 quilômetros por hora
o brasil está fora dessa área
mas já aconteceu um furacão no brasil
o furacão foi conhecido como catarina e
ocorreu em 2004
no sul do brasil em pelo menos duas
pessoas morreram quando o furacão autor
foi chegar encontrou dar mais tempo
possível o abrigo como esse e prepara-se
emprego com comida ou remédios casal com
a família precisa tomar regularmente
preste atenção aos sinais da natureza é
os meios de comunicação
deixe sempre nos locais onde você mora
limpos pois uma pequena lata de lixo
pode virar um grande troço e os
destroços para o brasil é que quando
você joga uma latinha de lixo eo algum
evento ou tempestade passe a lata pode
entrar em esgotos onde muitas vezes vai
para as ruas onde peixes podem morrer
e já pensou ficar sem peixes no brasil
tudo morre
obrigado